c'est un concept fun de fou c'est
Motorola qui le sort un truc qui est
vraiment intéressant c'est que vous avez
un écran de 5 pouces un écran de 5
pouces lorsqu'il est comme ça fermé vous
venez appuyer deux fois ici et il vient
s'ouvrir et ça vous sort du 6,5 pouces
il y a pas de nom derrière ils vous ont
marqué le Reaser pourquoi parce que Isis
live bon c'est marrant voilà c'est pour
rigoler vous êtes prêt on se regarde ça
c'est un nouveau concept phone moi
personnellement j'adore
c'est une nouveauté auquel on
s'attendait absolument pas ici
omwc devant l'arrivée Motorola avec un
concept phone un petit peu fou alors on
connaît Motorola on connaît les
smartphones de Motorola l'historique des
Motorola il a très jolie marque on a
derrière donc on est bien évidemment le
Razer le smartphone qui vient se plier
et je vous l'ai déjà présenté il y a pas
longtemps très honnêtement j'attendais
pas au tournant avec un smartphone comme
celui-là on connaît des technologies
enroulables on l'a déjà vu notamment
chez oppo et je suis très content de
voir arriver un proto comme ça un
conseil fun puisque un proto d'ailleurs
chez Motorola alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe on va regarder la techno si vous
très près et bien vous avez à l'arrière
un écran qui va venir monter et
descendre là il est juste en haut il est
ouvert et lorsque je rapplique comme ça
vous voyez qu'il vient s'enrouler pour
revenir ici donc en fait vous avez votre
écran qui va rouler sur un espèce de U
il va passer de là il va remonter là il
va s'ouvrir donc cette techno elle est
assez marrante parce qu'il vient pas son
rouler à l'intérieur comme une feuille
de papier sur lui-même non ici il vient
faire un petit chemin un petit
cheminement il descend là il remonte de
l'autre côté alors l'idée elle est pour
qui elle est pourquoi elle est pour les
personnes qui veulent pas forcément des
écrans très grands dans la poche un 5
pouces aujourd'hui c'est franchement
plutôt petit mais qui veulent lorsqu'ils
en ont besoin pouvoir l'activer et avoir
un écran plus grand 6,5 pouces c'est
grand je fais un double tap il se lève
une fois de plus vous avez aussi un
petit écran à l'arrière également qui
vous servira à des grandes notification
lorsque vous allez venir le poser à plat
sur une table voir vos messages voir ce
qui est écrit si et ça c'est pratique
lorsque vous voulez venir l'utiliser par
exemple pour faire des photos et bien ça
peut servir de deuxième moniteur
derrière pour la personne qui se voit en
photo si vous avez des enfants et que
vous voulez venir les prendre en photo
et que vous voulez pas qu'il se voit
mais leur indiquer de sourire et bien ça
vous mettra un grand sourire derrière
bref il y a sécurité qui sont assez
marrantes alors très clairement
aujourd'hui ce smartphone là comme il
est en l'état ne sortira pas c'est un
concept je suis pas sûr que Motorola il
dépensait de l'argent là dessus mais il
nous montre de la recherche à
développement et d'ailleurs c'est
intéressant parce que nous le montre ici
au MWC également on a un concept d'écran
d'ordinateur qui vient se déplier par
les nouveaux les nouveaux Motorola c'est
la même boîte donc on voit que la
modularité au niveau des écrans prend de
plus en plus son envol arrive de plus en
plus au niveau des smartphones bien
évidemment mais au niveau des PC ça se
déploie de plus en plus j'ai déjà montré
des PC qui venaient expliquer un peu
tous les côtés en fait plus ça coule de
voir ce concept folle chez Motorola
aujourd'hui ça me séduit ça ne sortira
jamais c'est vraiment pour vous proposer
un truc nouveau novateur alors les
usages on les voit si on vient regarder
par exemple sur Youtube et bien
lorsqu'il est fermé vous regardez en
tout petit c'est pas très grand sur du 5
pouces et lorsque vous venez l'ouvrir et
bien il va switcher automatiquement en
diagonale et vous allez avoir votre
grande vidéo YouTube ça c'est vachement
bien autre exemple vous voulez venir
taper un email et bien avec le clavier
qui est là et la partie mail au-dessus
avec l'expéd avec le destinataire c'est
pas très grand et bien il va s'ouvrir et
la paupière d'une plus grande espace
pour venir taper et écrire et une fois
de plus il y a plein d'usages l'idée
c'est la modularité c'est malin et ça
Motorola l'a bien compris donc comment
est-ce que vous trouvez ce concept fun
de Motorola est-ce que vous trouvez ça
fun est-ce que vous aimez ça oui non
quoi comment vous marquez bien
évidemment ça dans les commentaires moi
ça me plaît beaucoup alors on reparlera
probablement de concept fun à l'avenir
celui-là est vraiment franchement une
fois de plus une très belle surprise
donc dites-moi vous ce que vous en
pensez bien évidemment pensez à vous
abonner parce qu'on continuera à parler
de smartphone ici
omwc et bien évidemment après je vous
embrasse prenez soin de vous à bientôt
Ciao
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]